guys
welcome to compare and quick hitches
2020 edition
well we've got six quick hitches lined
up here and if you just give them a
quick glance
you might see a few different colors but
the construction is generally the same
let's go ahead and point out some
differences here throughout this video
show you
oh let's just wait for rosie there
really quick don't mind us
show you what actually makes these
things a little bit different
one of them is going to stand out from
the rest in a big way it's gonna save
you a lot of money make sure you stick
around
oh yeah really quick if you haven't done
so yet hit that subscribe button right
underneath the video make sure you read
through the description as well a lot of
helpful links down there
check out the other videos on the
channel here we go
okay so i'm going to go ahead i'll tell
you what each one of these quick hitches
is here you know who makes it the
manufacturer that kind of thing then
we're going to kind of go through
just some general um properties of them
you know weight dimensions
construction color adjustability and if
they require bushings or not
as far as pricing goes you can get that
on my website go to
goodworkstractors.com
it changes over time i don't really like
to put the pricing in here
i call this the 2020 version because i
did a version about two and a half years
ago i put the price
of one of these quick hitches in there
and the price went up it's gone up a
couple times since then
and so you know it's like putting my
foot in my mouth when i can't honor that
price because
the prices just go up over time okay so
this one right by me here is going to be
the work saver quick hitch this is the
one that
i've been selling over the last couple
of years a very popular choice very well
built
a good price point as well this green
one that you see here this can be the
john deere eye match you're going to see
all sorts of those all over the place
this next one up right here is going to
be a
tar river quick hitch okay and keep in
mind these are all category 1 quick
hitches as well
uh next one up here is going to be a lan
pride this particular model is a qh-15
on there next one up right here is a
nortec you guys probably haven't seen
this
on my website but i did just get these
in fairly recently and the last one
right here is going to be the brand new
one that i have the spiko quick hitch
okay so first thing here let's just take
a look at the general construction
probably one of the key differences
between
a couple different versions of this is
going to be in kind of this
gusset area here this cross bracing area
between the legs that come down
and then the top section okay so if you
take a look a lot of them are going to
have this thicker
chunkier beefier section here you can
see it there in the spiko
you can see it there on the nortec you
can see it oh nope not on the land pride
you can see it there on the
tar river you got a little bit right
there on the eye match
and then you're going to have it you
know that same chunkiness on the work
saver as well now
over here on the lamp if you look at the
back side there is a they do have a flat
piece right here okay flat piece of
steel
get you down take a look on the bottom
side it's kind of hard to see you know
but maybe you can see it there a little
bit better but this um
all the others that are going to have
that substantial cross bracing it's all
the way through
okay on the front and the back so that's
going to be one of the key differences
between these quick hitches now on a
general construction note as well you
can see on the top
hook where there's all the different
positions there okay that's going to be
pretty well standard
some might have an extra bolt hole or
two compared to some others we're
talking these bolt holes here where you
can adjust
the top hook in multiple positions there
was an old version of at least the eye
mask probably some others as well that
actually had just a welded
top hook so this wasn't able to be moved
and adjusted up and down which
is very convenient to do so keep that in
mind if you are shopping for something
that's in the used market and you see an
eye match or something similar
maybe just double check it has these
additional holes here where you can
adjust this top hook position
so while we're kind of staring at these
top hooks here too if you take a look
you see how this comes out here and then
it's kind of a longer taper if you take
a look at the
eye match for instance it's a pretty
narrow position from here to here with
not as much of a taper so you'll hear
some folks say they have trouble
with this top hook not kind of extending
out enough to be able to grab the top
link there on the three-point hitch you
can see there these
others all kind of for the most part
generally extend out a little bit
further okay
compared to the eye match just a point
of observation
they're all going to have these spring
handles that are on top here so if you
take a look this way
you can just you know rock that top
handle you can see
down here pay attention down here okay
when you open up the top handle
it retracts that okay and then you close
it back up on top of there
just the general functionality of all
these doesn't really matter you can see
there's levers on
on all of them too one for each side
there okay next up we're gonna do the
old weight test on here got the scale
out here hopefully you can see the uh
the the digital display right there if
you can i'll go ahead and repeat it but
i did add a piece of wood on here it's
reading 0.0 i zeroed it out with the
wood
i just need that on there to kind of
support the legs uh we'll go ahead and
get some weights
okay so spiko's reading in at 69.6
pounds
this is the nortec 56.6 pounds
land pride 68.6 pounds
entire river
56.0 i
match 65.4
well 65.2 it went down to
lastly is the work saver it does come
with this um
this top link here which i'm going to
take off
this is just for like um non-quick hitch
compatible
attachments if you can see that right
there kind of goes in and gets a little
bit more flexibility to connect
but also i just realized let's see the
spiko doesn't have the top pin so that's
probably just a few ounces there
that's gonna you know affect the weight
but not significantly
the work saver 70.2 pounds okay
okay i don't want to keep you hanging
too much longer but i want to get right
to the point here on why that spiko is
going to save you a bunch of money okay
it's going to save you a lot more money
compared to all the others every single
other one that you saw there
is going to require something like what
you see right here
now this big old rusty looking thing you
might see in brass color as well but
it's called a bushing okay it takes
what is a category one attachment and
turns it into a category three
attachment
for whatever reason category one quick
hitches nobody's ever explained it to me
need to get upsized to a category three
by use of this bushing which can be
upwards of forty dollars per set you
need to have a set of these bushings for
every three point attachment that you
would normally hook up directly to your
three-point hitch
with a category one no problem you need
to get a set of these bushings
for every single one that you want to
put in a quick hitch quick hitches are
just a fantastic tool to take the pain
out of the hook up process
they're not going to hook up the pto but
they're going to take the process
of attaching individually the three
points on the three-point hitch
and allow you to do that all at one time
so with that speako quick hitch there
you don't need those bushings so
depending if you have two three four
five six attachments
times that by just roughly forty dollars
for a ballpark and you can look at the
savings that you're going to see
and did i mention i can ship these quick
hitches out to you as well so yeah
i can ship the spiko i can ship the
nortec if you wanted i can ship
the tar river i can ship a used imatch i
don't get news of those and i can ship a
work saver so i can ship pretty much
what you see here
the land pride i kind of keep for
demonstration purposes but i do get used
eye matches in
the other stuff is going to be brand new
typically the speakers right now are the
big seller because again they don't
require those bushings so
get a hold of me if you'd like to order
one now let's grab a quick dimension
here we're going to go ahead and take
the outside to outside might come back
and do the inside to inside as well but
you're going to see these are all going
to be very very very similar in
in width overall okay not really too
concerned about the height from the
bottom link
to the top link because you can see
again with all the adjustability that
these have
you can play with this however you need
to you have more than enough flexibility
there to make that work so
main concern is going to be your width
down here in the bottom i just want to
show it to you that way you can see it
for yourself
outside the outside on the speako just
under 29 and a half
outside to outside on the nortec just
over 29 and a half
outside to outside on the land pride
just under 29 and a half outside the
outside on the tar river
just over 29 and a half outside
outside on the eye match
pretty much right on 29 and a half and
then outside to outside on the work
saver
just under 29 and a half there's going
to be manufacturing tolerances that come
into play that's going to
have that vary just slightly but
basically look at 29.5
outside the outside dimension okay now
really quick we'll go ahead and do the
inside to inside
you're going to be at 27 and a quarter
on the spiko
27 and a quarter on the nortec
basically 27 on the land pride
just over 27 and a quarter on the tar
river
about 27 and eighth on the i match
and 27 and eighth on the work saver
oh well i hope that was as much fun for
you as it was for me got a little bit of
a workout in there but
spiko okay i've been selling these
things like hotcakes right now but
got a lot of questions on them recently
so i wanted to show you how they
compared to the other models that are in
here
try to do that give you as much of a
apples to apples as possible
it's not perfect it's not scientific it
just it's me doing my thing okay so
i don't really care which one you buy as
long as you buy it from me
maybe i'll cut that out i might leave it
in but the point being the reason i'm
selling so many of these right now is
because of this requirement right down
here does not require the bushings it's
a direct fit to your category one pins
saves you a lot of money that way again
if there was some
majorly detrimental reason to why it
shouldn't be set up like this
i probably wouldn't be selling them okay
but the fact that there's not
and nothing has ever been said about the
reason why that
these bushings are required for all
these other quickitches here
seems like a racket to me so so whatever
i mean this is just information for you
guys helping make a better decision
because a lot of you guys can't come and
see this product in person
i ship it out all the time so it's just
to let you see
what they all are side by side you know
dimensional-wise are all built to the
same asae specification that is going to
be
controlling the dimensional tolerances
of everything that way it works and so
that means that not only is going to be
on the quick hitch side but also
the quick hitch compatible attachments
if something is branded as quick hitch
compatible
it's going to work with a quick hitch
okay you may just need the bushings if
you don't go ahead and get a speaker
as far as color hey right now they're
red i had some in black
you know get a can of spray paint paint
it whatever color you want
it's just a basic hunk of steel meant to
make your life a lot easier
get into it cheaper without the bushings
again if you haven't done so yet
consider hitting that subscribe button
right underneath the video
make sure you read through the
description make sure you check out the
other videos on the channel until next
time stay safe we'll see you soon